>>> JOINING US NOW IS FORMER
DEFENSE SECRETARY UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP, MARK ESPER WHO
IS PRETTY FRESH OFF OF A TRIP TO
TAIWAN AS WELL.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THIS
EXCLUSIVE REPORTING WE'VE SEEN
THERE.
HAS CHINA EFFECTIVELY BUILT A
NETWORK OF TROJAN HORSES USING
TELECOM IN THE U.S. AS YOU SEE
IT?
>> WELL, GOOD MORNING.
IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT CHINA'S
ESPIONAGE IN THE UNITED STATES
IS RAMPANT.
IT'S IN INFRASTRUCTURE AROUND
THE COUNTRY AND AS FBI DIRECTOR
CHRIS WRAY HAS SAID HE'S OPENING
UP A COUNTERESPIONAGE
INVESTIGATION NEARLY EVERY 12
HOURS.
WE HAVE KNOWN ABOUT THIS FOR
YEARS, IT'S A THREAT TO OUR
COUNTRY, A THREAT TO OUR
POSITION IN THE WORLD AND THAT'S
WHY, YOU KNOW, WE'VE GONE
AGGRESSIVELY AGAINST CHINA
ACROSS THE BOARD.
LOOK, THEY HAVE A STRATEGIC PLAN
TO DISPLAYS THE UNITED STATES AS
THE LEADING COUNTRY IN THE WORLD
BY THE YEAR 2049 AND THEY PLAN
ON DOING THAT IN THE MILITARY,
ECONOMIC, DIPLOMATIC,
INFORMATION AND TECHNOLOGICAL
SPHERES.
WE NEED TO BE VERY COGNIZANT OF
THAT.
>> HOW QUICKLY DOES THIS NEED TO
BE DEALT WITH CONSIDERING --
LOOK, THE TIMELINE THERE LINES
UP CERTAINLY YOU WERE AWARE OF
THIS WHEN YOU WERE DEFENSE
SECRETARY, IT'S NOT UNDONE.
IT'S STILL SITTING THERE ALL OF
THIS TECHNOLOGY.
HOW QUICKLY DOES THIS NEED TO BE
DEALT WITH?
>> LOOK, IT SHOULD BE OUT
IMMEDIATELY.
THAT SAID, I HAVE COMPLETE
CONFIDENCE IN THE DEFENSE
DEPARTMENT'S COMMAND, CONTROL
AND COMMUNICATION SYSTEMS, BUT
THIS IS A PROBLEM NOT JUST FOR
THE UNITED STATES BUT FOR OUR
PARTNERS AROUND THE WORLD AS
WELL.
I USED TO TRAVEL TO BRUSSELS FOR
MY NATO MEETINGS AND I WOULD
TALK TO OUR NATO ALLIES ABOUT
GETTING RID OF HUAWEI TECHNOLOGY
AND OTHER CHINESE TECHNOLOGIES
FROM THEIR SYSTEMS.
WE SAID IF THEY DIDN'T IT COULD
IMPAIR OUR ABILITY TO SHARE
SENSITIVE INFORMATION WITH THEM.
THIS IS PART AND PARCEL OF A
GRAND PLAN BY THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY TO SPY ON THE
WEST AND TO ACHIEVE DOMINANCE
OVER US.
>> SPEAKER PELOSI IS STANDING TO
GO TO TAIWAN NEXT MONTH, SHE'S
FACING PRESSURE FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE NOT TO GO.
PRESIDENT BIDEN RECENTLY SAID
THE MILITARY DOESN'T THINK THE
TRIP IS A GOOD IDEA.
DO YOU?
>> I THINK CHINA SHOULD NOT HAVE
ANY SAY OVER WHERE AMERICAN
OFFICIALS TRAVEL.
I THINK IF THE SPEAKER WANTS TO
GO SHE SHOULD GO.
AS YOU NOTED UP FRONT, I JUST
CAME BACK FROM TAIPEI, MET WITH
THEIR LEADERSHIP TO INCLUDE THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY ARE VERY FOCUSED ON CHINA
AND WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
UNITED STATES SUPPORTS THEM AND
AS I SAID ON THE ROAD, I BELIEVE
THAT OUR ONE CHINA POLICY HAS
OUTLIVED ITS USEFULNESS.
I WROTE ABOUT THIS IN MY MEMOIRE
AS WELL.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WE HAVE A
NATIONAL DIALOGUE ABOUT U.S.
POLICY TOWARD CHINA AND TAIWAN
AND MAKE SURE IT IS CREDIBLE,
DURABLE AND PRINCIPLED ENOUGH TO
STAND UP WITH TOUGH DECISIONS WE
MAY HAVE TO TAKE IN THE YEARS
AHEAD.
>> WHAT IS THE BENEFIT OF HER
VISIT AND DOES THAT OUTWEIGH
CHINA'S PROMISED REACTION?
>> WELL, CHINA ALWAYS PROMISES
TO REACT TO THESE THINGS, RIGHT,
AND SHE WOULD NOT BE THE FIRST
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE TO VISIT,
NEWT GINGRICH WENT THERE IN THE
MID TO LATE '90s AND
CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATIONS TRAVEL
THERE ALL THE TIME.
ONE OF MY FIRST TRIPS TO TAIPEI
WAS AS CONGRESSIONAL STAFFER.
LOOK, I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT AMERICAN OFFICIALS GET OUT
TO TAIWAN, GET OUT TO THE REGION
AND VISIT AND SEE WHAT THINGS
LOOK LIKE ON THE GROUND AND TALK
TO OUR LEADERS, THE LEADERS OF
OUR FRIENDS IN THE REGION AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY FACE.
IT HELPS THEM SHAPE BETTER
POLICY BACK HERE AT HOME.
>> YOU SERVED DURING A
TUMULTUOUS TIME IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, YOU WERE FIRED
IN NOVEMBER, NOVEMBER 9th OF
2020.
AS YOU'RE WATCHING THESE JANUARY
6th HEARINGS, WHAT ARE YOU
THINKING?
>> WELL, I WISH I WAS ABLE TO
SEE MORE OF THEM BUT LIKE MANY
AMERICANS I FOUND MYSELF STUCK
ON AIRPLANES OR AIRPORTS.
EACH HEARING AS I READ IN THE
PAPER THE FACTS ARE STARTLING.
I'VE BEEN SAYING SHOCKING BUT
NOT SURPRISING.
IT'S AN IMPORTANT SERVICE THEY
WERE PROVIDING TO RECOUNT WHAT
HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6th AND THE
DAYS AND WEEKS LEADING UP TO IT.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
UNDERSTAND OUR HISTORY AND THAT
THERE BE ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> YOU'VE SAID YOU WON'T VOTE
FOR HIM AGAIN, YOU'VE URGED
OTHERS NOT TO.
WHAT'S YOUR BIGGEST WORRY ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENS IF PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS ELECTED AGAIN?
>> WELL, NO, I WON'T SUPPORT
HIM.
I'VE ARGUED TO MY REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES THAT YOU CAN FIND THE
SAME TYPE OF CONSERVATIVE
TRADITIONAL REPUBLICAN POLICIES
BUT WITHOUT -- WITHOUT ALL OF
THE BAGGAGE, THE COARSENESS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE BECAUSE WE NEED
A REPUBLICAN LEADER THAT CANNOT
JUST UNITE THE PARTY BUT UNITE
THE COUNTRY.
MY CONCERN ABOUT DONALD TRUMP
TRYING TO RUN FOR OFFICE AGAIN
IS HE DOESN'T PUT COUNTRY FIRST
AND THAT'S A PROBLEM FOR ME, A
MAJOR PROBLEM.
I THINK HE HAS TO PUT COUNTRY
FIRST, LEADERS NEED TO LEAD AND
BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER AND HE
JUST DOESN'T HAVE THAT
CAPABILITY.
>> I KNOW YOU'VE SEEN THESE
NUMBERS ABOUT 10% OF THE
NATIONAL GUARD IS IN VIOLATION
OF THE COVID VACCINE MANDATE.
YOU HAVE ALMOST 60,000 GUARD AND
RESERVES WHO ARE CUT OFF FROM
PAY AND BENEFITS, THEY ARE NOT
TRAINING BECAUSE THEY'VE MISSED
THE DEADLINE.
WHAT CONCERNS DOES THAT RAISE
FOR YOU, ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING
HOW MUCH WE SAW THEM BE UTILIZED
DURING THE PANDEMIC.
THEY WERE ESSENTIAL.
>> YEAH, LOOK, THE GUARD IS
ESSENTIAL, I SERVED IN THE
NATIONAL GUARD.
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO 2020 WHEN
WE WERE DEALING WITH COVID IN AN
ERA WHEN IT WAS REALLY UNKNOWN
AND IF AT THAT TIME I HAD ACCESS
TO VACCINES, WHICH WE EVENTUALLY
PRODUCED UNDER OPERATION WARPED
SPEED, THEN I WOULD HAVE GIVEN A
SIMILAR ORDER FOR THEM TO BE
ISSUED, ASSUMING OF COURSE THAT
THEY WERE FDA APPROVED LIKE THEY
ARE NOW.
I THINK IT MADE SENSE TO GET THE
U.S. MILITARY INOCULATED, IT'S
IMPORTANT TO OUR READINESS, BUT
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS AN OUTGROWTH
OF THE PLIT AT THIS ZAGS OF THE
VACCINE AND THE VIRUS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE AND IT'S A SHAME
IT'S GOTTEN TO THAT POINT.
>> WHY DID IT GET TO THAT POINT?
IF YOU ARE LOOKING AT 10% OF THE
GUARD, 60,000 GUARD AND RESERVES
NOT DOING THIS AND IT'S BECAUSE
OF THE POLITICIZATION, I MEAN,
DO YOU DRAW A LINE FROM THAT TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
WHO IS TO BLAME HERE?
>> WELL, EVERYBODY POLITICIZED
IT, RIGHT?
IT CAME DOWN TO AN ISSUE OF RED
STATE VERSUS BLUE STATE IN TERMS
OF HOW THEY DEAL WITH COVID.
IT CAME DOWN TO SIGNALING
WHETHER OR NOT YOU WORE A IF I
SAY FACEMASK.
THE GUARD LIVES IN ITS
COMMUNITIES, REFLECTS THE VIEWS
OF THE COMMUNITIES IN WHICH THEY
SERVE AND SO I'M NOT SURPRISED
THAT GIVEN A FORCE THAT'S SPREAD
IN EVERY STATE OF THE UNION AND
TERRITORY THAT YOU WOULD HAVE
THIS TYPE OF REACTION AND
RESPONSE.
>> YEAH, THEY'RE RIGHT THERE ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
I ALSO WANTED TO ASK YOU BECAUSE
KARI LAKE A REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE
FOR GOVERNOR IN ARIZONA SAYS IF
SHE'S ELECTED SHE WILL SEND
ARMED NATIONAL GUARD TO THE
BORDER AND STOP PEOPLE COMING
ACROSS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF A PLAN LIKE
THAT?
>> WELL, I HAVEN'T SEEN HER
COMMENTS SO I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT SHE MEANS, BUT, LOOK, WE
HAVE HAD NATIONAL GUARD ON THE
BORDER FOR YEARS SUPPORTING THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
AND CBP IN PARTICULAR SO THAT'S
NOT UNUSUAL, BUT I WOULD HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT SHE MEANS.
I CERTAINLY DON'T SEE THE NEED
FOR ARMED GUARD AN ARMED
NATIONAL GUARD THAT SUGGESTS
MAYBE SOME TYPE OF USE OF FORCE
IN SOME WAY.
TO SUPPORT CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PROTECTION WITH SURVEILLANCE AND
LOGISTIC SUPPORT MAKES SENSE TO
ME, THAT'S THE TYPE OF
ASSISTANCE WE'VE PROVIDED IN THE
PAST.
>> SIR, WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING
WITH US THIS MORNING.
FORMER DEFENSE SECRETARY MARK
ESPER, THANK YOU.